[Applause]  the nominations for the Best Original  Song score are the babymaker music by  Fred Carlin lyrics by chill with Kim  Rhee by name Charlie Brown  music by Rod McKuen and John Scott  Trotter lyrics by Rod McKuen Bill  Melendez a now Shane adapted by Vince  Gilardi darling Lily music by Henry  Mancini lyrics by Johnny Mercer and let  it be music and lyrics by the Beatles  Scrooge music and lyrics by hustlin  brick coos adapted by Ian Frazer and  Herbert W Spencer and the winner is the  Beatles for let it be accepted for the  Beatles will be musical director Quincy  Joe  this is fantastic  I just wanted an excuse to get close to  it and I wish that the Beatles were all  here together tonight to receive this  but I have to get back to conduct the  orchestra on their behalf thank you very  much  [Applause]  [Music]